is a bishop please pay attention to what
I'm saying Mar Mari and a piece of
advice to Israel people of Israel you
will never find peace you will never
accomplish peace you will never live
peace ever until both Jews and Muslims
acknowledge Jesus Islam came in 635 ad
John is an eyewitness my dear Muhammad
we know there are many benefits to the
use of black seed according to the
authentic statements of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them that's why I use the black seed by
tesn and 50% of the profits from your
order will go towards establishing the
dean Center the musjid and mega dawa
Center use promo code the dean show for
15%
off and he was recently on the pbd
podcast with our friend Patrick bent
Davis so let's go ahead and listen to
this clip and we'll get your response to
it and kind of get your story in between
somewhere in there they talk about laws
I'll ask them are you fulfilling that
law of course not you're falling very
short of that law so don't tell me you
have to do this where you are failing as
a leader your Prophet failed those laws
your own Prophet failed them who
Muhammad and all the other leaders such
a reporter move and the and the very
reason why Muhammad faed because he's
dead their book says that but their book
also says about my Messi even though the
ISA in the Quran is not the Christ of
the the Holy Bible totally separate
people with we cannot claim something
that is not truthful I know truth hurts
I'm not offending people I'm speaking
the truth and if it offends you I'm
really sorry not I'm not sorry for that
but let me tell you one thing your book
says that Isa son of Mary went up to
heaven alive and he will come back to
judge the dead and the living if I ask a
Muslim who judges they will say God well
you're telling me this Prophet will
judge so which is which has the prophet
taken the role of God God has God gone
on vacation and he's come and take his
position no but Isa is the living
Messiah even their book says there's a
lot to unpackage here yeah a lot I mean
it's where do you where do you want to
start uh how about um two separate
individuals so he's saying that the
Jesus of the Bible and Jesus of the
Quran totally separate yeah I mean I
don't know where he's getting this from
um obviously we just went over in the
previous part of the discussion we don't
believe everything that the Bible says
about Jesus peace be upon him right but
it's the same person right we believe
he's a prophet we believe he's the
Messiah we believe that he's uh the son
of Mary of a virgin birth etc etc right
but we believe that the Christians
distorted the message of Jesus peace be
upon them they made him into a God and
now what he's trying to do here in in in
this segment is he's saying oh and the
Muslims are basically Bally have to
concede that Jesus is god notice what he
kind of did there he said oh even in the
Muslim book in the Muslim scriptures
that Jesus went to heaven alive and he's
going to come back which is true that
part is true we believe that isaam he
escape death and he will come back but
where did he get this business in our
scripture about that he is going to
judge the dead and the living that's not
the role of uh Jesus p be upon him when
he comes back to judge the dead and the
living the only thing that even if we
can give him right is that yes those who
follow Jesus peace be upon him when he
comes back who are on his side they're
going to be on the right side of history
inshallah but he's not in a position of
God judging the dead and the living in
the way that he's talking about it so
with all the respect to him I don't know
where he plucked this out of thin air
but we Muslims don't believe in what
he's saying so he's not he's not
representing our beliefs accurately and
I think that's something that we have to
note yeah I want people to um understand
this I mean and I asked many Christians
this who had had on a program and I
asked them do you get offended when we
say Jesus peace be upon them and they
smile they right away smile if we take
it back because they'll call us Muslims
Antichrist but you have this strange
relationship with the Zionist on this
end and you have the Christians
supporting this and and if you look into
it they're actually the Antichrist
exactly they're actually the ones if you
look into and we we don't want to repeat
the things that are said about you know
something a soft version of it is common
criminal said by Ben Shapiro what's a
common you're calling Jesus a common
criminal if you call Jesus a common
criminal in Islam you go to the Hellfire
exactly uh so we love Jesus but now
historically academically if someone
this is a f let's just unpackage this
rationally this is a false This Is A Lie
uh because this can be proven this is
this this is the same
individual uh that we're talking about
it's not like he's trying to make it
seem like this is a totally different no
individual no exactly I mean it's
complete Distortion and you know this is
no disrespect to Patrick B David I'm not
blaming him for anything but this guy is
supposed to be an expert he's supposed
to be representing the Christian
religion he's on the program speaking
about Islam and with all due respect to
the platform
he's he's distorting Islam he's not
representing our belief accurately he
could disagree with our position but
don't say that Muslims we believe in our
holy scriptures that it says that Jesus
going to come back to judge the living
and the dead implying that oh basically
Muslims believe that Jesus is God too
because God everybody knows is is the
judge on Judgment Day so je if Jesus is
the judge according to Muslims then what
he's in the role of God he's implying
that oh basically Muslims believe we
don't don't believe that so they have to
you know I hope that maybe Patrick will
see this and and or some of his viewers
will see this because this needs to be
clarified I think this um uh priest or
Pastor whatever he calls himself I think
he should be questioned about where are
you getting this from you're asserting
this about Islam it's not true Let's uh
touch upon this at the same time you're
because I've interviewed so many people
hundreds upon hundreds and really what
fascinated people there's so many
different things but the basic teaching
that really draws the hearts the common
sense the logic you know it just blows
everything away that pure monotheism
toed in Islam here o Israel the Lord thy
God is one there's no confusion about
this worship one God and Jesus repeated
it in the new test Jesus over and over
and over now you can take and we'll get
into some of those ambiguous verses uh
before Abraham was I am what else can
you think about um whoever seen me seen
the father what I and the father are one
one all these can be explained context
to but then when you look at the clear
clear verses right the father joh 173
yes this is life eternal that they may
Know Thee the only true God and separate
and distinct and Jesus Christ whom you
have sent what does that sound like the
sh the testimony of
fath and what so there's no God but
Allah yes and Jesus is sent by God is a
messenger of God that's what we believe
that's exactly what we believe and at
the time of Jesus that's what true
Muslims those who submit themselves to
the will of God they would have said
just like we say there's no God but and
there's none worthy of worship except
the one and only true creator and what
the prophet Muhammad uh peace and
blessings be upon Him is sent by that
one and only true God how long did you
because there's a lot going on right now
there's uh emotions right now for our
Christian friends and neighbors this
makes sense uh they did a study over 50%
I believe it was uh Christians
Evangelical I think 30% don't believe
Jesus Is God he's a he's a good he's a
good man a good teacher so we confirm
even what the Bible says isn't it true
that the Bible calls him a prophet of ma
Nazareth uh what other the terms are
used but there's no way messiah messiah
we we confirm word of God we confirm son
of Mary son of Mary we confirm all this
exactly but is there anywhere in your
studies and was this also a catalyst and
this something that you had an affinity
towards this basic belief of just
worshiping the god of Jesus the one who
created Jesus the one Jesus worshiped to
you can you touch upon this yeah so uh
just for people who don't know I have a
background I was raised as a Roman
Catholic my entire family is Roman
catholic christian and um you know I
always believed in God Edie I was never
became an atheist or anything like that
alhamdulillah that never made sense to
me it's obvious that there's a cre right
um but this idea that Jesus peace be
upon him was God and man at the same
time and he was God but yet he came and
died for our sins but God doesn't die
none of this stuff ever made sense to me
so I never really believed in it and
when I read the Quran and its message
was so clear was so direct was so simple
and I realized wow I could believe in
Jesus peace upon Him Islam is the only
other religion that makes it a tenant of
faith that if you don't believe in Jesus
peace be upon him as a righteous prophet
and Messiah you can't be a Muslim
there's no other religion like that now
Christianity has gone too far because
they affirm that but then they say he's
God also but how does it make sense he's
God and man at the same time well God is
Immortal and eternal he can't die but
yet he came to die for our sins and you
know just t watching back cuz I forgot
to mention this what that guy mentioned
marari or whatever his name was on the
pbd show he said something like oh what
is this uh like is go is the Muslim God
absent why is Jesus becoming um why is
Jesus becoming uh the judge well hold on
a second what are you talking about you
believe in a God that came and died so
you believe in an absentee God why did
your God have to come and die in order
to save mankind if he's all knowing all
merciful all powerful why would God come
and die I mean this doesn't make any
sense who running the world who running
the world so you're accusing us of an
absentee God I'm sorry sir but all
respect you believe in absentee God
that's an important point that I want
people to note and go and play that clip
back which he accused US based on a
false representation of our faith and
yet it's actually his faith that has
that understanding but yeah
fundamentally and this is a simple
Message of Islam when I read the Quran
Eddie for the first time I actually read
the Quran with the wrong intention mhm
sincerely I read the Quran with the
wrong intention actually to refute the
Quran can you believe that and actually
like many do and Allah subhana tala
Allah the most high he still guided me
wow I don't know why he must have saw
something in me right
look you're doing this for the wrong
reason but look I he he still guided me
to Islam at the end of the day with the
wrong intention when I read the Quran
and I read they believe in one God they
worship one and only true creator it's
been the same message from the first man
Adam peace be upon him all the way to
the final Prophet with Moses and uh
Jesus peace be upon both of them in
between the all came with the same basic
message worship one and only true
creator right everyone is responsible
for themsel the one of the verses and
and it really stuck out for me coming
from a Christian background no soul
shall bear the burden of another and
this is actually in line with the Old
Testament right the son will not be put
to death for the Father the father's not
put to death for of the always made
sense to me I'm saying Jesus and in in
our religion and also the Christians
claim this too although a stock for thew
they actually say Paul actually says in
Galatians that Jesus is a curse I mean
could you think Eddie of a Muslim saying
that Jesus peace be upon Him is cursed
they say Jesus is God how could God
become a curse for mankind it's just
completely Blasphemous for us and so
what I'm saying here this concept never
made sense to me in Islam we have to
believe in Jesus as a prophet as a
messenger who did many miracles and and
we can't say he's cursed this is
completely forbidden in Islam how is it
the case that this innocent man this
Innocent Prophet of God died for the
sins of all the guilty this is like me
and may Allah protect me from this just
like me committing a crime and I show up
in the American courtroom and I said
judge I'm sorry but I admit it I'm
guilty I did it I shot John let's just
say you know God forbid yes and my
friend Eddie is sitting in the courtroom
right they they convict me they say okay
he's admitting to it we even caught him
on tape everything they got all the
evidence and then the sentencing comes
down and right before the judge is ready
to put the hammer down and tell me I got
life in prison or death penalty or
whatever it is Eddie stands up and you
say you know what judge I know Jake did
it I had nothing to do with the murder
but I want to take his place can you
kill me can you take my life instead of
my friend Jake would they they accept
that Eddie would the family be happy
punishing you for something that I did
to their family member of course not
this is not Justice they would say BFF
take I'm sorry Eddie with all due
respect we got to take this guy out of
here he's he's causing a problem in the
courtroom yeah right they wouldn't
accept that this is not Justice and in
Islam we believe that mankind was
created with what we call an Islamic
terminology the F which is the basic
innate disposition not only to know the
one only true God but also to have basic
moral Concepts like this a concept of
Truth and Justice that we know this is
not correct this doesn't make sense
coming from our creator would he want us
to believe in such confusion the Bible
says that God is not the author of
confusion but yet you're telling me God
uh became a man right and God can't die
and he's Immortal but yet he died for
our sins and innocent people aren't put
to death for their the sins of their
father or the sons but Jesus became
cursed God became cursed right God
forbid God became cursed to die for the
penalty and the sins of evil
mankind what is this this doesn't make
any sense to anybody with common sense
or some decency or understanding of
human Justice it just doesn't make sense
and so when I read the Quran and it gave
an alternative narrative that made much
more sense
I embraced Islam and I you know
alhamdulillah Allah subhana T guided me
at the end of the day even though I had
the wrong
intention alhamdulillah brothers and
sisters we've acquired the future Dean
Center property and we want to get the
mashid open first it's all coming along
we're installing the doors we can make
woodoo we've installed the carpets we
have many details to finish up but it's
coming along alhamdulillah we need a new
roof we need new windows and we need a
minbar that's right we need a minb for
the mid now if all of you want to be a
part of history and help build a house
of worship build a Masjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
you